igor matvietz is jewish and lives in the
eastern german city of hala
he shows us around the market square
where most days a well-known neo-nazi
organizes a rally as soon as he spots
igor
threats come over the loudspeaker
it's telling that even after the attack
this kind of thing can still take place
in the middle of hala
i'm sad to say it's quite normal for him
to insult ordinary citizens
things like this just fuel conspiracy
theories
and help to radicalize the hala attacker
the incitement stops just short of
criminal activity
but it helps to foster a climate of fear
the extremist
also targets the media accusing
journalists of lying
the police are keeping a low profile we
ask officers off camera
whether it's right the jewish citizens
should have to listen to this far-right
extremist
they tell us the right-winger also hears
things a reference to civil rights
campaigners
halla's jewish people tend to keep to
themselves
and that saved lives during the attack
the solid wood synagogue door
protected people inside from the
gunshots
on october the 9th last year on yom
kippur
the most important jewish holiday a
heavily armed neo-nazi tried to storm
the synagogue
the attacker fired repeatedly at the
door and threw hand grenades
failing to gain entry the attacker then
shot dead a woman passerby who
challenged him
he then opened fire at a nearby takeaway
food shop
killing one diner both of the victims
are commemorated at the place where it
happened
[Applause]
the leader of hala's jewish community
was among the fifty worshippers who
escaped the attack on the synagogue with
their lives
the effects however are still being felt
then helicopter in the lufthansa the
sound of a helicopter makes me uneasy
which it never did before in the same
way
i never had any problem with the
fireworks on new year's eve
[Music]
diesel manslaught max privorotsky
recently found two swastikas in front of
his office building
he was further unsettled when he
witnessed a police officer
covertly clearing a swastika away
it's not good to feel so insecure feel
that you can't entirely rely on the
police and other authorities
that's really
most of hala's jewish community are
reluctant to go out in public
eagle matvietts does venture out but
remains cautious
i think most jewish people would not be
happy to walk around hala wearing a
kippah
you just mentioned it's no great
surprise that hala's jewish community
does not feel safe
so why are neo-nazis allowed to spread
racial hatred on a daily basis
in the market square since the attack
last year the mayor has prioritized
countering anti-semitism
we wanted to ask him about this but his
office said
he was too busy to talk to us
with me in the studio now is benjamin
knight who covered the aftermath
of the hula attack for deutsche weller
benjamin welcome
the trial of the suspect begins tomorrow
what do we know about him well he's uh
28 years old now
he lived with his mother he's he's kind
of a
pathetic figure quite a lot i mean he
in the video that he obviously filmed
himself committing the thing and
streamed it live on the internet and in
the video he
he sort of described himself as a loser
and he's he's getting it all wrong
and um his attorney is who's defending
him
he said that he's the kind of person who
uh blames his own misery on
other people a lot of the time and what
we kind of know is that he he was
deliberately trying to copy the
christchurch attack which happened a few
months before in a mosque and at this
time he wanted to
kill as many people as possible in a
synagogue that was his he was
extremely anti-semitic and uh he had a
there was
there was a psychological assessment of
him which found that he was basically
obsessed with two things which was
one was building guns all the guns that
he made were homemade
and the other thing was anti-semitic
conspiracy theories
now you covered the aftermath of the
harley attack for deutsche welle and
you've also been back there
recently what does the city feel like
now
well it's not like i could tell you that
you know the whole city is in shock and
trying to work out what they're going to
do with the situation it's not that's
not how
people function now it's like like in
the aftermath in a few days afterwards
there was like
um uh you know you know there was a
human chain formed a symbolic
human change around the synagogue to
show solidarity and thousands of people
were out
in the market square and i think but now
like nine months later
it's not as if there's much has changed
like there's
things have just settled down and and
the attitude to the far right because we
saw
in the clip then that there was um
there's a there's a there's a local
neo-nazi kind of
a notorious guy who does regular uh
anti-semitic
protests there now they're not very big
there's just like a two or three people
there but he shouts into the street but
people just kind of
accept it you know that people just
think oh he's just part of the furnish
it's like
there's and and the only people who show
real outrage
are like anti-fur activists and um it's
not
like a it's people just kind of get on
with their lives you know
it seems extraordinary benjamin that a
man in germany can stand in the middle
of a square
shouting anti-semitic abuse essentially
and that is
okay is that as you mentioned
really acceptable in eastern germany i
mean
was there any political fallout in the
east after this attack for example
yeah i mean it's not as if like people
don't like it people are repugnant you
know there's a sort of repugnance
against these
this that type of thing but it's not as
if there's
thousands of people protesting anymore
against anti-semitism and against uh the
far right and
um i think yeah i
i think from a political point of view i
think a lot of the the politicians are
more kind of saying oh it didn't really
you know
this is nothing to do with hello we
don't want to impugn the people of hala
and that is kind of also like a natural
reaction but it's not as if there's
there's a really a big oh um
i don't think i don't think the
politicians really know what to do in a
situation like this because this
you know and they often like uh
emphasize oh this is just a lone wolf
kind of figure and but we have to kind
of ask like obviously he was like a
this kind of loser character but why is
he then therefore anti-semitic
that isn't really clear we leave it
there for the time being dwa reporter
benjamin knight
thank you very much for coming in thanks
you